This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. this episode today, as so many of my favorite episodes are, I was actually suggested by a listener, a listener called Josephine, who sent me this message, and she's given me permission to read it out loud and see if any of you may relate. This is what she had to say.
Hi, Gemma, it's been a while since I felt any kind of emotion, and I'm not trying to sound dramatic, I mean, truly. Happiness, sadness, excitement, they've all disappeared. My childhood dog recently died and I felt nothing. I got a big promotion that I wanted for a long time, also nothing. One emotion I am feeling is fear, fear that I'll never feel the same way again. I can link it back to some really bad anxiety I had almost a year ago. Around that time, I started to intellectualize almost all of my emotions before I allowed myself to fully feel them.
And now I feel like I've ruined my brain by cutting off its pathway to expression permanently. please any advice I need and would love for you to do an episode on how to actually feel my feelings. So I got this message and firstly thank you Josephine for sharing but I got this message and I immediately knew I needed to talk about this. In fact I actually had a whole other episode planned for this week but this one just felt so much more like important because Josephine like me too. I am here with you. I'm experiencing the same kind of emotional blunting and the same kind of poor communication between me and my emotions. You know, I feel happiness and I confuse it as something bad. I feel sadness, grief, anger, stress.
I push it down and say I'll get to that later. I also, much like you, intellectualize my emotions as a way of getting out of feeling them, you know, over-analizing every possible cause, explanation and consequence. until I'm exhausted. And you know what? I don't feel particularly good about it and I don't feel like it's a particularly great way to live. The absence of any negative emotions
doesn't necessarily make your life a happy one because your emotions all use the same systems. All 34,000 distinct emotions we can feel are operating across the same neural pathways across all the same cortexes of the brain. And that's why nostalgia and regret feel so similar. Passion and anger. Trust and vulnerability.
Anxiety and excitement. Grief and gratitude. They feel very similar. So you turn off one. You turn off regret. You turn off anger, vulnerability, anxiety, grief. You also turn off nostalgia. You also turn off passion.
Trust. Excitement. Gratitude. And I think a lot of us are finding ourselves in that very position where we've tried to feel, we've tried to manage our negative emotions in a way that's actually meant we've prevented any intense emotion at all. I think a reason for that is that we're scared, not of our actual emotions, we're scared of our feelings about our feelings. Like, let me explain this. I know it sounds like a little bit strange, but, you know, if I feel sad, I feel like that's a bad
thing and I feel like it's the end of the world. If I'm angry, I worry that something is wrong with me. So it's not that the sadness is bad. It's not that the, you know, the grief or the anger is bad. It's that I believe that it's going to make me feel miserable or have some further on consequence. This whole experience, this whole pattern, this is known as metacognition or meta-emotions. My emotions, our emotions about the possibility of certain emotions. And if that sounds complicated to you, it most certainly is, and it's complicated for our brain. and it's difficult for us to work through that and feel like we can actually feel our feelings.
So the two big questions we're really left with is why. You know, why does this happen and how? How do I fix it? How do I convince myself? I'm not at the mercy of my emotions and actually let them back in and feel human and feel connected again? Well, my lovely listeners, we are going to. to discuss exactly that. We are going to explore the psychology behind all of this and so much more.
Be prepared to go deep, maybe shed a few tears because today I really want us to all leave feeling in touch with at least one emotion we've been suppressing. Just one. That's all I want at the end of the day. So without further ado, let's get into it. So we need to talk about this first. We need to talk about what being detached from our emotions actually looks like. I was literally, I was about to say, what does it feel like?
But, you know, that's the actual problem we're dealing with. What does it look like? Not being able to feel your feelings essentially means you've put up some kind of wall between you and the actual feeling. So it's not necessarily the absence of any emotion at all. You are not broken. The emotions are still there. It's just that when an emotion comes up, you might feel it for just a second.
perhaps you notice it and then you start over-analysing or you get freaked out that it's going to come out too large and too loud so you distract yourself or minimize or adopt any number of coping strategies. After long enough, you can no longer name what the sensation or emotion even is. And in some extreme cases, you might also take direct action to completely, avoid the trigger. You know, if someone has hurt you or broken your heart, you would perhaps consider and tell yourself, well, they don't even exist anymore. And I'm never going to think about them again, meaning that a lot of the, you know, deep grief or betrayal or the emotions that you should be working through because of that experience remain unheeled, remain untouched. Maybe
you're really struggling because you've got like a terrible grade on a uni assignment and you're such a perfectionist and this is just like the most awful thing you might try and manage that and not feel the feeling by completely disengaging with your studies altogether or completely ignoring any upcoming assignments because you don't even want to give the illusion of trying so this is known as avoidance and it's often a precursor to not feeling your feelings not even putting yourself in the circumstances or the situations in which that might even be possible so When you feel out of touch with your feelings, when you're experiencing numbness, maybe a delayed emotional response. So something bad happens, you don't really think about it until a month down the line.
When you are avoiding emotional situations, when you're experiencing apathy, when you feel like, yes, you may not have been sad for a while, but you also haven't been happy. There is a word for this. It's called emotional blunting or in medicine, reduced effect. display. The best description I've heard of that describes what emotional blunting really is, it actually came from a patient involved in a case study on this experience. And this patient was experiencing intense, emotional, numbing and blunting. And she said, often what this makes me feel like is I feel invisible. I feel like I'm a ghost. I watch my family engaging with each other, but there is an invisible barrier that keeps me from joining them.
This was what another individual had to say in a similar article. The world around me often seems incredibly superficial, like I am simply going through the motions and can't connect to my environment. If I was to reach out and touch that wall or reach out and swim in the ocean, I wouldn't be able to feel it entirely. So that is what happens when you cannot feel your feelings. You just feel like both of these descriptions from true, different patients, two different clients, talk about something between them and the real world,
something that has been put there a long time ago, or because of a situation that they didn't feel like they can control. So let's talk about the reasons why we may get to a place of being unable to connect with our emotions. The first one that is very present is being stuck in survival mode or experiencing chronic stress. Now, you may hear that and think, I'm not chronically stressed. I'm going to skip this section. I'm fine. I'm not burnt out.
I'm fine. You might not even realize that you are because recent research suggests that around seven out of ten of us, seven out of ten of the people listening are chronically stressed. I'm going to say that again, 70%. When I heard that, and actually I heard it in Mel Robbins' new book, I was shocked. But the more I thought about it, I wasn't surprised. Our brains were designed for a very different world than the one we currently live in. We were really designed for a slower, less stimulating, less intense lifestyle.
And now, nowadays, when we are constantly being debarded with information, with a constant to-do list, productivity guilt, and then let's add on financial instability, uncertainty about the future. And, oh, no, you know, you're in your 20s, so you need to have it all figured out right now. That sounds exhausting because it is and it takes a lot of mental resources to ensure that we don't like just collapse in on ourselves like a dying star. Something has to give in those situations. It takes a lot of brain power and willpower to keep up with that much mental activity. And sometimes our brain thinks, well, if we can just dull our emotions for a little bit, if we can shut down our emotional processing systems, well, amazing.
That's great. That's one less thing to worry about while we get out of survival mode. Obviously, that's not sustainable. The reason many people end up in this state even after the stress has passed is because when they do allow themselves to feel their emotions, they are so intense after so many months or years of not feeling them, that we kind of forget what it means to truly feel. and it's yeah the best what I can say is it's intense and so we fall into a bad cycle of feeling safer and out of attached state because we are out of practice we are out of practice with feeling and so it's easier to revert to the other extreme of nothingness because you know the whole system has now become dysregulated where the presence of even a slight emotion feels so profound after lack of
exposure. So I just said this one key word here, disregulated. Again, your emotional processing systems are still there. It's not like someone has gone into your brain and scooped out a part of your cortex and been like, cool, now you can't feel anything anymore. It's dysregulation of a system that is still present and active. So why has this dysregulation occurred other than chronic stress? well maybe it won't come as a surprise that it does begin way back in childhood for many of us. Not all of us, but I think the majority of you can relate to the following series of events. So as children, when we were angry, frustrated, trying to be heard, trying to get our point across, crying out of pain or sadness or exclusion, we were often shut down, either in subliminal or
very obvious ways. We were hushed, we were scolded, we were yelled at, even punished. I remember one time, I think I must have been like six years old and I don't know, we were like on the playground. Someone like pushed me. I was like feeling excluded. We were like playing some game and everyone kept running away from me and I was really, really sad about it and I felt so lonely and I went up to a teacher and I'm sure I was annoying her. Like I'm sure. I'm sure I was annoying her. but I was crying to her being like, no one wants to play with me. Like no one wants to be my friend. And she was like, oh, get over it.
Like, just go away and get over it. Like, life is unfair. And that's like a distinct part of my memory. And, you know, those reactions, the reactions we have of parents, teachers, adults in our lives, is one of the primary ways we learn what is and isn't appropriate when it comes to our emotional reactions. and unfortunately we often end up learning that big emotions aren't acceptable and may even result in an uncomfortable outcome or a bad outcome for us from those repeated experiences because if it happened once i'm sure it happened again and again we actually begin to deny those emotions ourselves and over time that act
of suppressing our feelings becomes an unconscious automatic process we don't need someone else to do it it for us. And eventually you don't even realize that you're doing it. Let me give you some of those unconscious ways we still revert to to suppress our emotions that you might not even realize you're doing. The first one, and I think this is massive major, huge in our 20s, abusing alcohol to dampen our anxiety, dampen our insecurity, our fear or our stress. This one is, I think, the most popular for people in their 20s because drinking is so socially acceptable but alcohol is also you know I'm going to say this and I don't know it to be misconstrued alcohol is a fantastic way to not feel your emotions and it's a fantastic way in the moment to feel less stressed and to feel a little bit happier and to have that
buzz in the moment afterwards you begin to associate those happy momentary feelings with the alcohol and you start pursuing the buzz over and over again, meaning that obviously alcohol takes such a toll on your brain, such a toll on your body, but also you have this huge catalogue of memories and experiences that just go untouched and unprocessed, but don't go away. So alcohol is one of the ways that we manage not feeling our feelings. The other one is overworking.
You know, you feel a negative feeling come up. You immediately start working. You start working late. you commit to more and more things. That feels satisfying in many ways and is, you know, well, again, socially acceptable in today's hustle culture. Doesn't mean you process your emotions? No. It doesn't.
It's just a distraction. This next one is also one that probably a lot of you can relate to, especially during this generation and it's escapism through TV shows or social media. I was having a conversation with someone recently where, well, we were talking about death and we were were talking about grief and as it was getting rather heavy we were both sharing you know we were both bonding she picked up her phone and she started like aimlessly scrolling and like playing tic-toks out loud and i was like it wasn't rude i was just like oh i'm so sorry you know let's stop talking about this like if you want to talk about something else i totally get it and she like looked up from her phone and she was like pardon and i was like oh you know like i just i didn't want to be weird about it
I was like, oh, you know, you're on your phone. Like, you probably don't want to talk about it. And she looked at her phone and she was like, I honestly had no idea I was even doing that. She was like, I had no idea I was even on my phone. And she was still like, kind of semi-engaging in the conversation. But at the same time, she was like scrolling and scrolling and scrolling. And I was like, and we both, like, were sitting there being like, wow. Wow, that's just like a complete, like the presence of social media is just like dulled your emotional response.
and in some ways, perhaps you're leaning on that in many situations without even realizing. Our phones are like an emotional shield because they can pull us in with all their dopamine offerings and make us feel great and distracted in the moment, but disconnected in the long run. Finally, one of the ways that we avoid feeling our feelings, my personal favorite, over-intellectualizing, over intellectualizing every emotion and rationalizing it to the ninth degree so that we never have to feel it. So let me explain the psychology behind why we do this. Psychologically, intellectualizing is linked to something called cognitive avoidance, where our brain is essentially trying to bypass distressing emotions by shifting focus to logic and reason,
creating that kind of sense of detachment because our emotions are not sensations. They're not things that are happening to us. They're ideas, they're abstract concepts. I'll give you some examples of this going through like a big breakup or your first heartbreak and instead of grieving it, you might be obsessing over the psychology of attachment styles, you might be over-analyzing the entire history of your relationship, rationalizing exactly why it wasn't meant to be, being quite scientific and dissecting every little moment that you had together. you may also find that you overthink any kind of emotion that you're experiencing by saying
why do I feel this way? What's the psychological explanation? What's the science? What's the neurobiology? When is it going to go away? What's the timeline? Instead of just saying this is uncomfortable, who cares why it's happening?
I'll get through it. I'll say it again. I am very guilty of this. In fact, I think my podcast is a reflection and is evidence of how guilty I am of this because, you know, I really did start the psychology of your 20s to break down the emotions I was experiencing in a rational, logical way, i.e., I was over-intellectualizing them, and I've definitely gotten better, but I do find it's quite an interesting thing that often people who are
overthinkers and who feel really big emotions really lean into intellectual resources or research or articles or fact or science as a kind of emotional crutch so they don't actually have to feel the thing so intensely. And by doing this, what's actually happening is that our prefrontal cortex, which is responsible for reasoning, is dominating over our limbic system, which processes emotion, basically dulling our emotional response and providing temporary release from emotional pain. Let's quickly talk about some other reasons for this attachment. Trauma is one of them. The emotions of the past are scary and temperate. terrifying and big and sometimes we are afraid that if we open that door, you may not be able to
close it ever again, especially since we are not taught, really in any capacity in school, in life, how to handle big, uncomfortable emotions. We can also experience emotional numbness because of our current environment or context. Maybe it's a particularly stressful period at work, at school, you're experiencing grief, heartbreak, even when a situation is dangerous. dangerous people often emotionally shut down. It's why you see a lot of people experiencing long-term shock, even amnesia during war, during natural disasters. Our brain is like, we cannot handle this.
If we were to feel this all at once, we would surely break. So to survive physically and mentally, let's just shut this off for a little bit. Finally, the reason you might be experiencing emotional blunting is because of certain medications that also can create this sensation, one of them being antidepressants. Now, this is not to fearmonger or scare you, especially if you are on any kind of antidepressant or considering it. I'm currently on 20 milligrams of lexapro a day and we have a complicated relationship, but overall my lexapurot has helped me tremendously. But I have, however, noticed that whilst it makes those hard distressing emotions less sharp and painful and biting,
it does also make the good emotions feel a little bit less fulfilling. Like, I remember being in Paris last year and being like, wow, I've never been to Paris before and this is beautiful and there's the Eiffel Tower and I was like, I'm trying to get there, I'm trying to get there, like maybe I should be more excited. And I just couldn't get to the point of excitement that I knew maybe three years before I could have gotten to. It also means I don't get to the levels of depression I could have gotten to, so a win is a win. But for some people, they do find this quite difficult.
So what exactly are the consequences of not being able to feel our feelings? The thing is, and I am going to sound like a broken record, but our emotions haven't disappeared. We just aren't listening to them. All the systems that make emotions possible are still there. It's still firing as usual. we have just wrapped them up in bubble wrap and layers of tape and said, okay, all fixed. It's better this way.
We're just going to leave it as it is. But if you suppress something for too long, have a guess what's on the other side. It's a huge eruption. It's like a volcano. Perhaps we would even experience what we would classify as an emotional or mental breakdown where one day there's that final straw, that final thing that cracks you or your defense.
slip or something so intense happens you can't cope and again all the stuff that you have pushed behind the wall comes flooding in we do not want to get to that point not just because it's paralyzing but also because when that happens it doesn't matter what you're doing who you are where you are your whole world stops it's like that quote you know take a break before your mental health chooses when to take one for you that's exactly what i'm describing here Also, you know, you're alive, you're human. This is part of the experience is to feel and feel very, very deeply. I think life is meaningless without that.
So I want that for you, even if it's scary, I really do. I want you to have a full rainbow of human emotional experiences. So what exactly should we be doing to slowly get back to our emotions and feel them deeply and accurately? I'm so glad you are. Thanks for asking. Stay with us. We're going to talk about it very, very soon. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts.
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. served in Arizona.
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think we need to begin this section by myth-busting what feeling our emotions is and is not, because if you haven't done it for a while, I think there can be a lot of hidden misconceptions that aren't particularly useful about the truth around emotional expression and emotional connection. Feeling your feelings. it is not being a slave to your emotions.
It is not being excessively emotional in a way you cannot control. It is not a sign that you are weak or too sensitive. It is not a reflection of your strength or worth as a person. Feeling your feelings does not mean the end of peace and serenity. That is what your brain is trying to convince you, but we have to ignore it. emotions do not equal unbridled chaos. Here's what feeling your feelings actually means. It means you are more connected to others.
The love that you may feel for people is deeper and you can fall deeper into your relationships with them. It means more joy and moments of real deep contentment. It means you can make beautiful art, write beautiful things, create beautiful things. Feeling your feelings also means more energy and focus in general because you're not constantly using your finite cognitive resources to force something down that doesn't need to be suppressed. It also means you get to be more human. That's the biggest selling point for me. In my mind, I think accepting this and
你对人们感受到的爱会更深，你能够与他们建立更深的情感联系。这意味着更多的快乐和真正深深满足的时刻。这意味着你可以创作美丽的艺术，写出优美的文字，创造美好的事物。感受你的情感通常也意味着更多的精力和专注力，因为你不再不断消耗有限的认知资源去压抑那些不需要压抑的东西。这也意味着你能成为一个更真实的人。对我来说，这是最大的卖点。在我的脑海里，我认为接受这一点并
being like, okay, I'm prepared to feel my feelings is like the moment you're in these huge waves and this huge storm out at sea and you've been fighting and fighting and fighting and you are so tired from fighting and being rocked back and forth and you slip under the water and you think you've failed only to realize like, oh my God, I can breathe under here. This whole time I could breathe under here and wow, look at all this cool stuff. Like it's beautiful under the water. That's really the metaphor that I love for this. So enough of that, no more metaphors. Here are my actual tips for feeling your feelings. Firstly, it goes without saying, go to a mental health professional if this is really, really intense because they are going to dive into this for you in ways you cannot imagine
并且觉得，好吧，我已经准备好去感受我的情绪了，这就好像你在海上遇到了巨浪和狂风暴雨，你一直在抗争、抗争、抗争，你因为抗争和被左右摇晃而精疲力竭，然后你滑入水中，以为自己失败了，却突然意识到，天哪，我可以在水底呼吸。一直以来我都能在水底呼吸，哇，看看这些酷炫的东西。水底下真的太美了。这真是我用来形容这一现象的最喜欢的隐喻。好了，废话少说，不再用隐喻了。以下是我关于如何去感受情绪的实际建议。首先，不言而喻的是，如果这种感觉真的非常非常强烈，请去看心理健康专家，因为他们会以你无法想象的方式为你深入剖析
and just give you so many fantastic individualized, personalized recommendations and help and assistance. So that's your first step. But if you just want some more daily practices that you can do at the same time, well, I think firstly, you've got to stop telling yourself that you're just an emotionless person. There is literally no good that can come from that. No one is born that way. Seriously, tell me about a child who was born and didn't cry and didn't giggle or get fussy.
并为你提供大量绝佳的、定制化的、个性化的建议、帮助与支持。所以这是你的第一步。但如果你只是想要一些可以同时进行的日常练习，嗯，我认为首先，你得停止告诉自己你只是一个没有感情的人。那样做绝对没有任何好处。没有人是生来如此的。说真的，给我讲讲哪个孩子出生后不哭、不咯咯笑或不爱哭闹的。
Emotional reactions are hard, wired into us. It's just that you maybe can't recall a time when your emotions were permitted. And considering many of us can't remember anything before the age of three because of something called infantile amnesia, if you started, if your emotions started being hushed and put down and scolded around that age or even earlier, of course you cannot remember a time when you had a serious connection to your emotions because by the time you were making conscious memories, the damage was already done. So when you hear yourself saying, I'm just, I don't feel my feelings that deeply. I'm just, I'm not that sensitive. I'm quite cold. I'm just a cold, cold person. I need you to ask yourself, how did you come by this realising?
情感反应是深植于我们基因之中的。只是你可能记不起曾经被允许展露情绪的时期了。考虑到我们很多人因为所谓的婴儿失忆症，记不清三岁之前的任何事情，如果从那个年纪甚至更早开始，你的情绪就被压制、贬低和斥责，那么当你建立有意识的记忆时，伤害已经造成，你当然记不起自己曾与情绪有过深切连结的时期。所以，当你听到自己说“我只是……我感受不到那么深的情绪。我只是……我没那么敏感。我挺冷漠的。我只是个冷冰冰的人”，我需要你问问自己，你是怎么得出这个认知的？
who told you about that about yourself? Like who made you believe that? And also the fact that you're listening to this episode, my friend, that shows that you know it isn't true. Because you and your emotions obviously have a more nuanced and complicated relationship than that. So after acknowledging, yes, you are an emotional feeling, deeply feeling person and that's okay. We need to get back in touch with the physicality of our emotions. Often, and this is according to research at Columbia University, which I love to quote,
是谁对你说了这样的话？是谁让你相信了这一点？而且，我的朋友，你现在正在收听这个节目，这就表明你知道这不是真的。因为你和你的情绪显然有着比这更微妙、更复杂的关系。因此，在承认了“是的，你是一个有情绪的、有深刻感受的人，这没关系”之后，我们需要重新与情绪的身体感知建立联系。通常情况下，根据哥伦比亚大学的研究（我非常喜欢引用这个研究），
the first way we feel our emotions is physically. Think about when you were a child, before you were taught to suppress these parts of you, you felt your emotions all over in your body, in your nerves, in your fingers, in your face, before you ever had a word for it. And there is this amazing study from the University of Alabama that talks about how most of us can name a physical sensation better than an emotion. So we need to start there. Try first by leaning into the embodied sensation of an emotion by asking yourself where in your body, on your body, this emotion tends to make itself known. There is an amazing resource that I personally love called the
我们感受情绪的第一种方式是通过身体。想想当你还是个孩子的时候，在你被教导去压抑这些部分之前，你在全身各处——你的神经、你的手指、你的脸上——都能感受到情绪，甚至在你拥有描述它的词汇之前。哥伦比亚大学有一项惊人的研究指出，我们大多数人比描述情绪更能准确说出身体的感觉。所以我们需要从这里开始。首先尝试去顺应情绪带来的身体感知，问问自己这种情绪倾向于在你身体的哪个部位、身体的哪个地方表现出来。有一个我个人非常喜欢的惊人资源，叫做
emotion sensation wheel and it was created by someone called Lindsay Brahman. Personally, like I cannot recommend it enough. Basically if you're feeling tense, if your hands are numb, your foot is tapping, your lip is cold, you're hot, you're shivering, you feel electric, whatever it is, where you feel something in your body, which is often what we notice first, you can trace that back to a feeling. So this is actually called a somatic check-in and it's really an incredibly important tool. Honestly, when an emotion comes up, when you feel it in your body, give it a name but also treat it like a game treat it like a challenge to collect your emotions to feel as many of them as possible like strava i know this sounds strange to talk about like a running app
情绪感觉轮（emotion sensation wheel），它是由一个叫林赛·布拉曼（Lindsay Brahman）的人创建的。我个人真的极力推荐它。基本上，如果你感到紧张，如果你的手麻木了，你的脚在抖，你的嘴唇发冷，你觉得热，你在发抖，你感到浑身触电般的，无论是什么，只要你在身体里感觉到了什么——这往往是我们最先注意到的——你就可以把它追溯到一种感觉。这实际上被称为躯体检查（somatic check-in），它真的是一个极其重要的工具。老实说，当情绪涌现时，当你在身体里感受到它时，给它起个名字，但也把它当作一场游戏，把它当作一个收集情绪、尽可能多地体验情绪的挑战，就像Strava（运动软件）一样。我知道在讨论情绪的节目里谈论一个追踪英里数的跑步应用听起来很奇怪，
that tracks your miles in an episode about emotion but sometimes when i'm like oh i shouldn't be feeling that there's a bad feeling i want to avoid this i think no no it's like i've got some cool like stamp book or like a passport where I'm trying to collect all the emotions like this is a game I'm learning here I'm collecting experiences that remind me that I'm human and that I'm alive and that my environment impacts me and that I can reach out and touch and feel everything it you know I am here and I don't know it's moving and shifting into a place of wonder but also having a beginner's mindset about it as well. If you're not at that stage yet, that's totally okay. If you're not at the stage, but you still want to feel something, I want you to try a practice called a somatic release. I recommend a whole
但有时当我感到“哦，我不该有这种感觉，这是一种不好的感觉，我想避开它”时，我会想：“不，不，这就像我有一本很酷的集邮册或一本护照，我试图收集所有的情绪，这就像是一场游戏，我在学习，我正在收集各种体验，这些体验提醒着我，我是个人，我还活着，我的环境会影响我，我可以伸手去触摸和感受一切。”你知道的，我在这里，我不知道它正在转变和过渡到一种惊叹的境界，同时也带着一种初学者的心态。如果你还没有到那个阶段，那完全没问题。如果你还没到那个阶段，但你仍然想感受点什么，我希望你尝试一种叫做“躯体释放（somatic release）”的练习。我在这档播客里推荐了
lot of tips on this podcast. You know, I do two episodes a week. There's a whole lot of advice being given. But this one has to make my top three of the things I personally use. Somatic release. I'm going to use the Harvard definition here because I like it the best. Somatic release, allows your body to express deeply painful emotions and experiences by using your body as a medium. If trauma is stored in the body, that's where it should be targeted. And somatic, by the way, I should say, is the Greek word for body. So, yes, essentially, it's the release of emotion through the body. Somatic release could include something I like to call crazy dance.
非常多的建议。你知道，我一周做两期节目。有大量的建议给出。但这个绝对能进入我个人使用的排名前三的技巧之列：躯体释放。在这里我将使用哈佛大学的定义，因为我最喜欢它。躯体释放允许你的身体通过将身体作为媒介来表达深深痛苦的情绪和经历。如果创伤储存在身体里，那就是应该针对它下手的地方。顺便说一句，Somatic（躯体）这个词是希腊语的“身体”。所以，是的，本质上，它是通过身体释放情绪。躯体释放可以包括我喜欢称之为“疯狂舞蹈”的活动。
I love crazy dance. And if I'm feeling like really down or crap or numb, I like put on a song in my headphones and I just like move my body ridiculously. And I mean like that's the aim of the game for it to look like crazy dance. The song I'm loving for this right now is I was like, should I make something up? No, I'm going to tell you the truth. It's tambourine by Eve. And I need to listen to that song and understand why, if you know what it is, you understand
我很喜欢疯狂舞蹈。如果我感觉真的很沮丧、很糟糕或麻木，我喜欢在耳机里放一首歌，然后我就开始毫无章法地扭动身体。我的意思是，这正是这个游戏的目地，就是要看起来像是一场疯狂舞蹈。目前我最喜欢用这首歌来做这个练习——我当时在想，我是要编造一个吗？不，我要告诉你实话。是伊芙（Eve）的《Tambourine》。我需要听这首歌，并明白为什么，如果你知道它是什么，你就会明白
where I'm a bit like, oh, that's a bit of an embarrassing song to say. But I love like early 2000s music for my crazy dances. And I just find that anything I'm feeling in my body is so much better represented for me right now through that kind of expression. For other people, it's stretching, it's yoga, it's a practice movement or pattern of movements that they've made themselves whilst they're breathing to really connect with an emotional state and to really flow through the intensity of an emotion, it's running, it's anything that makes you feel in touch with your body.
为什么我会觉得“哦，说这是一首有点尴尬的歌”有点不好意思。但我喜欢2000年代初的音乐来作为我疯狂舞蹈的伴奏。我只是发现，通过这种表达方式，我身体里感受到的任何情绪，对我来说现在都能得到好得多的展现。对其他人来说，这是拉伸，是瑜伽，是他们自己在呼吸时创造的练习动作或动作模式，以此来真正与情绪状态建立连接，并真正顺应情绪的强度洪流，或者是跑步，是任何能让你觉得与自己的身体产生联系的活动。
You know, if your favorite way to avoid feeling your emotions is to over-intellectualize them like me, talk therapy sometimes just isn't useful anymore because it just gives you further opportunities to do that. This is what I've found. I just don't need to talk about my problems at this stage in my life. I don't need to dig any deeper into the past. don't need to talk through it anymore with the therapist.
你知道，如果你最喜欢用来逃避感受情绪的方法是像我一样过度智力化它们（over-intellectualize），那么谈话疗法有时就不再有用了，因为它只会给你进一步这样做的机会。这就是我的发现。在我人生现阶段，我根本不需要谈论我的问题。我不需要再往过去更深地挖掘。我不再需要和治疗师一起讨论它。
Like, I've done it. I've done the work. And I'm at a stage where anything a therapist says, I promise you, I've already overthought at 2 a.m. in the morning. I've already rationalized every single dimension and way of seeing this thing. And that's not arrogance. Like, truly, these people are a lot smarter than me. It's just that, you know, that's how my brain likes to think about things.
就像，我已经做过了。我已经做过这些功课了。我现在的阶段是，治疗师说的任何话，我向你保证，我在凌晨两点就已经过度思考过了。我已经对这件事情的每一个维度和看法进行了理性化分析。这并不是傲慢。真的，这些人比我聪明得多，只是，你知道的，这就是我的大脑喜欢思考事物的方式。
And it puts in a whole lot of time to try and trying to help me. avoid feelings by rationalizing them away. Really wish it wasn't that way, but what I found is that the best way to counteract the plateau that I had reached in my therapy journey was to start actually getting into where my emotions felt physically and providing or pushing for emotional release and catharsis through exercise, through dance, through movement, swaying with an emotion. It really, really helps. My third strategy for feeling your feelings is one that I think will hopefully stop you from being afraid of what that would mean.
它投入了大量的时间来试图帮助我通过理性化来逃避情绪。真的很希望情况不是这样的，但我发现，打破我治疗旅程中遇到的停滞状态的最好方法，其实是开始深入了解我的情绪在身体上的真实感受，并通过锻炼、舞蹈、运动、伴随着情绪摇摆，来促进或推动情绪的释放和宣泄。这真的非常有帮助。我关于如何感受情绪的第三个策略，我想它有望让你不再害怕这意味着什么。
And it's called the 90 second rule. So this was created by the neuroscientist Dr. Jill Bolt Taylor. She's pretty well known for having a major stroke when she was in her 30s and she was already a neuroscientist and basically using herself as like a test subject to, you know, understand the. brain better through her experience. She also did some pretty amazing research looking at how long our emotions actually last. And she found that most of the time an emotional reaction cannot last longer than 90 seconds, unless we keep re-triggering it with our thoughts, i.e. by overthinking or not letting it go or not allowing ourselves to feel it properly. So it keeps returning again and again and again but basically what that means is that when an emotion arises for you set a timer for 90 seconds
它被称为90秒规则。这是由神经科学家吉尔·博尔特·泰勒（Dr. Jill Bolt Taylor）博士提出的。她相当有名，因为她在30多岁时曾严重中风，当时她已经是一名神经科学家，基本上是通过将自己作为实验对象，来更好地通过自身经验理解大脑。她还做了一些非常了不起的研究，观察我们的情绪实际上能持续多久。她发现，大多数时候，情绪反应的持续时间不会超过90秒，除非我们用自己的想法不断重新触发它，例如通过过度思考、不愿放手或不允许自己充分去感受它。所以它才会一遍又一遍、没完没了地卷土重来。但基本上这意味着，当情绪向你袭来时，为它设定一个90秒的计时器
and just sit with it find a cozy spot breathe feel it's going to feel scary and like the emotion's going to take over and then you realize that it won't and suddenly 90 seconds is up and it's passed you cannot be frightened anxious in the depths of grief sad whatever it is You cannot be like that forever, not even continuously for more than a few hours, even if it feels that way. You know, according to Dr. Jill, not even for more than 90 seconds. So, because of that, it's okay to let yourself feel, knowing that this emotion isn't going to consume you because it just has no way of doing that. Again, make your mission here. Your mission here right now is to explore every emotion like some great traveler who is able to,
然后静静地与它共处，找一个舒适的地方，呼吸，去感受。它会让人感到害怕，觉得情绪就要失控了，然后你会发现它并没有，突然间90秒到了，它就过去了。你不可能永远处于惊恐、焦虑、深陷悲伤或任何其他情绪之中，甚至连连续几个小时都做不到，尽管感觉上好像是那样。你知道的，根据吉尔博士的说法，甚至连超过90秒都做不到。所以，正因如此，允许自己去感受是没问题的，因为你知道这种情绪不会吞噬你，因为它根本没有办法做到这一点。再次强调，你在这里的任务是：你此时此刻的任务就像某个伟大的旅行者一样，去探索每一种情绪，他能够
to come back and tell people about what they found and make great art and write about it and tell us stories about it. This emotion cannot hurt you. There's a fantastic TED talk I love called You are Not at the Mercy of Your Emotions, Your Brain Creates Them, that I love to watch when I need this reminder as well, this reminder that you can tap into your emotions and let them give you a rich, sensational, emotional, interpersonal experience without losing control. My final big tip for getting back in touch with your emotions is to voice memo or film yourself when you are having a particularly intense emotional experience, but keep it just for you. I'm going to explain why that's important and why I love doing it. When I went through my first major breakup, when I was in
回来向人们讲述他们发现了什么，创作出伟大的艺术，写下关于它的文章，并向我们讲述关于它的故事。这种情绪伤害不了你。我非常喜欢一个精彩的TED演讲，叫做《你无需受制于你的情绪，你的大脑创造了它们》（You are Not at the Mercy of Your Emotions, Your Brain Creates Them）。每当我需要这种提醒时，我都很喜欢看，这个提醒就是：你可以在不失控的情况下，探究你的情绪，让它们带给你丰富、感官化的、情感化的、人际间的体验。我重新与情绪建立联系的最后一个绝招是：当你经历特别强烈的情感体验时，给自己录音或拍视频，但只限于你自己留存。我要解释一下为什么这很重要以及为什么我喜欢这样做。当我经历人生第一次重大失恋时，那时我正处于
my like early 20s and late teens, maybe even, I can't even remember at the stage. Obviously I was devastated. I was so, so sad and just torn apart and I couldn't sleep and I couldn't eat and everything was a mess and I started filming myself in those moments. I started filming myself, you know, walking around my campus, going on a hike, crying and talking about where I was at in this like journey to get over this person. It was so raw and it was so real and it was just for me. That's the important part. It was just for me that it really just allowed me to be like, this actually, this is kind of beautiful. This is kind of beautiful. And I'm really just giving myself permission to feel this with no shame and no blame.
20岁出头或者青少年晚期，甚至可能更早，在这个阶段我都记不清了。显然我当时崩溃了。我非常非常伤心，心碎欲绝，无法入眠，吃不下饭，一切都一团糟。就在那些时刻，我开始给自己录像。我开始录下自己在校园里闲逛、去远足、哭泣，并谈论我在走出这段感情的“这段旅程”中处于什么位置。它是那么的原始，那么的真实，而且这一切都只是为了我自己。这才是重点。这一切只为了我自己，它真的让我觉得：其实，这挺美的。这挺美的。我真的只是在允许自己去感受这一切，没有羞耻，也没有指责。
And I'm watching it back and I'm seeing exactly where this is touching me and exactly where this is impacting me. I actually still have those videos. And I know it sounds really, really bizarre. But I think the beginning stages of feeling your feelings is like grabbing onto any glimmer or shimmer or instance of the possibility of an emotion and just grabbing it and letting it take you wherever you, it needs to take you. Like I think about Tinkerbell in a weird sense, and I know that's a weird thing to bring in here,
我回看这些视频，看着这一切究竟是在哪里触动了我，在哪里对我产生了影响。其实我到现在还保留着这些视频。我知道这听起来真的很离奇、很古怪。但我认为，感受情绪的初阶段，就像是抓住任何一丝、一闪而过或可能存在的情感火花，紧紧抓住它，让它带你去它需要带你去的任何地方。就像我脑海中莫名其妙想到了小叮当（Tinkerbell），我知道在这里引入这个比喻很奇怪，
but this like flash of light and this like flutteriness of this fairy thing and this small thing and that's your emotions. And in the early stages, if it's sitting with you, if it's passing through, grab it. Even if it's not an emotion you particularly want to feel, grab it. document it, make it known, let yourself sink deeply into the experience because it is a human one. And remember, please, avoid distracting yourself when this comes up. Avoid distracting yourself through escapism, through alcohol, through work, through the need to rationalize your emotions, through, you know, endlessly keeping yourself busy.
但这种闪光、这种仙子般微小事物的轻颤，这就是你的情绪。在早期阶段，如果它伴随着你，如果它正在流经你，抓住它。即使它不是你特别想感受的情绪，也抓住它。记录下来，让它为人所知，让自己深深地沉浸在这种体验中，因为这是一次属于人类的体验。请记住，当这种情绪出现时，避免分散注意力。避免通过逃避现实、通过酒精、通过工作、通过强行理性化你的情绪、通过（你知道的）让自己没完没了地忙碌来分散注意力。
It is such, you know what, the reason that we want to do it is because for a while it is such an effective strategy to do that. That's why you're doing it, because it does actually help. It helps you right now. It will not help you in the future. And I see a lot of people, the older they get, lose more and more of who they are because for so long they've suppressed their emotions that as they get older, none of it just feels as special anymore. And they just don't really know, I just feel like they're just not really having the depth of experiences and they're not really searching for emotions and sensations the way that people really should be in this life. So that's not so much a psychological perspective. It's more of a spiritual value-based perspective or belief-based perspective
你知道吗，我们之所以想要这样做，是因为在一段时间内，这样做确实是一种非常有效的策略。这就是你为什么会这样做，因为它确实管用。它在当下能帮到你。但在未来它帮不了你。我看到很多人，随着年龄的增长，越来越失去自我，因为他们长期压抑情绪，以至于当他们变老时，一切都感觉不再那么特别了。他们真的不知道——我总觉得他们没有真正体验过深刻的情感，也没有像人们在这个生命中真正应该做的那样去寻找情绪和感官体验。所以这与其说是一个心理学视角，不如说是一个精神上的、基于价值观的视角，或者是我的信仰视角，
that I have that any time you try and convince yourself and say, this feels terrible, this feels awful, I shouldn't be feeling this. Ask yourself, well, if I shouldn't be feeling this, why is this emotion even around then? Why does this emotion even exist? Because if it wasn't useful, or helpful if there wasn't some specialness to it, it wouldn't be here. And yet it is, so I'm going to honor it, I'm going to feel it. That's all I have time for in this episode. I really hope that it helped you. I hope that this like dissection of, you know, this dissection of this experience of
那就是：每当你试图说服自己并说“这感觉太糟糕了、太可怕了，我不该有这种感觉”时，问问你自己：“好吧，如果我不该有这种感觉，那这种情绪为什么还会存在呢？为什么这种情绪还会出现？”因为如果它毫无用处、没有帮助，如果它没有某种特殊之处，它就不会存在。然而它确实存在，所以我要尊重它，我要去感受它。这就是本期节目我有时间分享的全部内容了。我真的希望它对你有所帮助。我希望通过对这种
emotional blunting and emotional numbness. I don't hope that you can relate to it, but I hope that if you can relate to it, you got something out of it and you can implement these strategies and that you feel scene and that bringing it back to the very first thing I said at the start of this episode, I hope that you're leaving this feeling in touch with just one emotion that you're going to be having today. Make sure to send this episode to a friend, a family member, a colleague, a partner, whoever, who may need to hear it. If you've made it this far, my loyal listeners, I know there's like a group of like 50 of you, 50 to 100, and always make it this far. I want you, what's the
情感迟钝（emotional blunting）和情感麻木体验的剖析——我不希望你能感同身受，但我希望如果你能感同身受，你能从中有所收获，并且能够付诸实践这些策略，让你觉得被看见。回归到我在本集节目开始时说的第一句话，我希望你离开时能够与今天即将体验的仅仅一种情绪保持连结。确保把这期节目分享给可能需要倾听它的朋友、家人、同事、伴侣或其他任何人。如果你能坚持看到这里，我的忠实听众们，我知道大概有一群50人左右，50到100人总是能坚持看到这里。我想问你们，今天的是什么
emoji for today? What's an emoji that represents feeling your feelings? Oh, I think you should do a crazy dance emoji. Whatever you think like crazy dance looks like, drop it in the comments so I know you've made it this far. Leave your questions, your episode suggestions down there as well. I love engaging with you in that space because, you know, it's not like Instagram or TikTok where anyone can jump on board. It's just the listeners of the show. So I'll see you down there. But until next time, please make sure to follow along. Give us a five-star review. pre-order my book because it comes out in less than a month, which is wild and we will talk about that a whole lot more. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself, and we will
表情符号？代表感受情绪的表情符号是什么？哦，我认为你应该发一个“疯狂舞蹈”的表情符号。无论你觉得“疯狂舞蹈”看起来是什么样的，把它留在评论区，好让我知道你坚持看到了这里。也请把你们的问题、对节目的建议留在评论区。我喜欢在那个空间里与你们互动，因为，你知道的，它不像Instagram或TikTok那样任何人都可以涌入，这里只有节目的忠实听众。所以我们评论区见。但在此之前，请务必关注我们。给我们一个五星好评。预购我的书，因为再有一个月它就要出版了，这太疯狂了，我们接下来会对此进行更多的讨论。但在此之前，请保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们
talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
很快就会再聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了坚韧意志、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字2和百分号。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me.
我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill, on the 80s.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），谈论80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方进行都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有多少男人穿着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一档iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。